éducateur spécialisé
assistants sociaux ils étaient des
milliers partout en france ce mardi à
battre le pavé dans l'espoir d'obtenir
plus de reconnaissance dans la capitale
les salariés du secteur du social ont
tenté de montrer leur ras-le-bol
accentuée par la crise sanitaire parmi
les employés les plus expérimentés
certains craignent une fuite des jeunes
diplômés vers d'autres métiers on a des
collègues qui commence à partir parce
que ils bossent dans les collections
tellement dégradée qu'on est les patrons
qui sont dans des logiques de
marchandisation d'appel la prochaine
cetera donc on a une chute collègues et
les collègues qui sont assez beaucoup de
jeunes qui se disent moi j'ai fait j'ai
appris un métier pour faire vraiment
sociale m'occuper des jo à accompagner
les gens précarité des gens handicapés
cetera est ce qu'on fait passer on
travaille à la chaîne on fait un truc
industriels on n'est pas revalorisé on
n'est pas
on n'est pas ce qu'on semble pas est
estimé par le par le pouvoir public donc
on en a marre valoriser les métiers du
secteur du social et du médico-social
une revendication essentielle pour
l'ensemble des manifestants à toulouse
aussi des centaines de personnes se sont
mobilisées les manifestants ont pointé
du doigt le manque de moyens au
quotidien mais également des salaires
dont le bas niveau dénote un manque de
considération
concrètement les protestataires
demandent une augmentation de 300 euros
minimum pour l'ensemble du secteur eh
bien nous avons perdu 30 % de pouvoir
d'achat depuis 25 ans et ça c'est plus
possible les gens n'en peuvent plus les
conditions de travail sont extrêmement
dégradées on va voir à accueillir de
plus en plus de personnes des cas de
plus en plus difficile et avec du
personnel de moins en moins on va dire
fort mais je vais avoir de plus en plus
de mal à allier ma vie professionnelle à
ma vie personnelle parce que j'ai de
moins en moins de de pouvoir d'achat
simplement en première ligne depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire les salariés
du secteur du social s'estiment lésés
par le ségur de la santé les salariés
protestent notamment contre le fait de
ne pas avoir bénéficié des
revalorisations accordées aux soignants
et certains salariés du médico social
cette colère pourrait perdurer et
croître au fil des semaines en raison de
la cinquième vague de covile 19 dans
l'hexagone